retour à la ferme du caruaru colline vis
à vis de fermières direction la cuisine
ici on transforme directement la
production et j'ai l'habitude du tablier
qui n'aime pas ma taille pas de gâteau
au menu on revisite les délices
traditionnels installés pour créer un
parti sérieux alors je pose mes oeufs
donc nous voici sur notre petit plan de
travail pour faire tes petites recettes
alors c'est une recette c'est facile qui
se fait depuis le xiième siècle dans la
région s'appelle cette recette gagnante
alors ça s'appelle le casse muzio qui se
mesurent l'accent berrichon à une
signifie pas souhaité signer la
signification c'est qu'on faisait le
pain on sortait le pain du four et on
enfourne et les casques luz où les
enfants s'entendent pas savais qu'il y
avait un petit dessert pour eux ils se
précipitaient pour le four et quand ça
sortait du four to show is brûler le
museau très bien alors on est parti pour
un banquet studio il vous faut 800 g de
chèvre frais généraux mais moi toujours
bien que lafarie de cire 400 grammes on
n'est pas à son grand frère et les oeufs
8 ma bonne dame n'a oublié de poser le
sel une pincée suffit tu vois regardes
tu vois les mains des petits morceaux de
fromage blanc demain l'étape d'après
alors maintenant c'est de faire les
petits pots quai moi je trouve que c'est
joli d'époque et oui c'est joli mais
c'est quoi
avec enel quoi une fois récolté l'époque
et on enfourne une demi-heure à 140 et
ensuite on va s'installer pour casser
une telle cote à chrétien il ne sait
m
alors et 30 minutes plus tard
on voulait pas montrer
[Musique]
ça ressemble un peu à une gouge eh oui
c'est à dire semble sauf que la gougère
ses crocs mais c'est de la pâte à choux
donc on n'a pas la même texture mais si
nous dans l'aube où certains voient pas
ça c'était hyper moelleux fut pas si on
voit ces fonds dans on a bien le goût de
fromage pendant ses très bons mais je
vous encourage à le découvrir en tout
cas j'ai appris beaucoup de choses te
remercie de m'avoir accueillie mais moi
je vais continuer à goûter tout ça et
puis bah une prochaine fois ça me
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]